Patrick Reed joins us here in studio 57
with the green jacket on welcome I'm
wearing my green dress it's not quite
the green jacket but we're thrilled to
have you here and what a thrilling
victory on Sunday talk about that
feeling on the 18th when you sink that
putt oh you know it was it was just a
sigh relief to dream about you know
winning the green Jack as a child
growing up you know having all those
putts on the practice greens you know
with all your friends I god this is the
win the green jacket and have that dream
come true is you know it's just it's
just a surreal moment and now has it
fully set in yet because you know ever
since ever since the tournament we
finished the tournament it's been just
you know I go go go
so you know once you know I can kind of
sit down and reflect on the week and
reflect on the event you know I'm really
gonna be able to see how amazing it
really was for those of us watching at
home it was really an exciting finish
because there was a moment with jordan
Spieth pulled even with you for 14 under
how aware were you of where other
leaders were on the board
oh I I knew exactly where everyone was
so I'm the type that I always like to
know where I stand where I'm at
whether it's Thursday morning before I
even tee off to kind of see how the Golf
Course is playing all the ways that he
wasn't looking at the board you know
yeah capture that you know he might have
not been like like focusing on the
leaderboard but you know you have a
leaderboard directly behind the green on
seven as you're walking up directly on
behind the green on eight directly off
the tee on ten directly behind the green
on after buy-side agreed on 13 walking
to 14 tea so you definitely know where
you're at but you know more people look
at it more than others and you know me
personally I always love staring at the
leaderboard I love to know where I'm at
because really it also being in that
position when you're in the final group
it allows you to see okay well do I need
to go out and play really aggressive do
I need to make birdies or you know is
par oh okay and that's a key when you're
in that moment in feeling that pressure
are you
thinking clearly or occasionally
thoughts coming in thinking oh my god
I'm a I'm a win this whole thing
no yeah that's that's the thing about
golf it's such a mental game and my
whole motto the entire week was hey just
do you be who you are just play golf you
know because a lot of times coming in
the majors people overhype
you know players are like oh I have to
play well I have to make birdies I have
to do this
and now all sudden mentally you have
just built that situation so great that
you can't execute the shots properly and
so I tried to basically bring it back
down to reality that it's a golf
tournament
it's 18 holes you gotta hit a golf shot
I mean it's whoever has the lowest score
after setting two holes wins it's still
the same thing well yes it's the Masters
compared to our regular gig but
psychologically you have to try to bring
it back down to earth that you know it's
it's golf you got to play it and you
know that was the hard part
you literally bring your family to work
your wife Justine was your caddy before
she became pregnant with your first
child talk about that dynamic and having
her there with you I mean it it's it's
unbelievable having Justine out there
with me you know she's my rock you know
without her you know this wouldn't have
happened I wouldn't be here and you know
she she's the one that you know got us
started with going through the Monday
she was caddying for me during the
Monday qualifiers and you know we went
six for eight she helped me get through
queue school we won our first event in
2013 together and you know then when we
started a family
you know we she passed the reins over to
Kessler who you know is her brother to
caddy for me and it has been awesome but
she's been there walking practice rounds
inside the ropes helping us you know
figure out golf courses in our game
plans
well her Lilly Pulitzer pants that she
had on I'm sure you've heard her now
sold out she was quite the star online
for the outfit that she wore to but talk
about Tiger Woods cuz this was his
return and I knew you yeah I know you
grew up sort of worshipping at the Tiger
Golf you know the way he plays you know
it mean it's awesome half Tiger back you
know and to have him back playing well
you know it's one thing that if you were
to you know come back and kind of ease
into it but to have him come
backplate Valspar fifty second make cut
Fiat lead I would see some glimpses of
you know the old Tiger coming back and
playing some good golf and you know
that's one of my dreams I want tyre to
come back and play how he how he has
played because you know I haven't
experienced that I haven't you know I've
seen on TV but I haven't been I
experienced it in life and I would love
to see that and he has been reaching out
to you as well glad to hear that you've
been talking Thank You Patrick great to
have you on congratulations again thank
you